it's a question that causes much debate
and with brexit looming no small amount
of concern in the city what's the
world's pre-eminent financial center
when a new report says it's once again
London after five years we're New York
in the top spot however the same report
says New York is likely to overtake once
again and that Dubai and Mumbai are
quickly emerging as a global financial
hubs for Mo'Nique MELAS ahead of
regulatory consulting and often folks
joins me now she wrote the report so
Monique is important to stress this is
not your opinion this is industry
professionals that you surveyed exactly
so this is the c-suite in the financial
centers in the world so New York London
say Paris as well Hong Kong Singapore
and also the offshore centers well
everything I hear from Wall Street
suggests at New York's going bang
gangbusters how come London's overtaken
it again I think that breakfast has
provided the backdrop to this I think
that it's an increased focus on London I
think we don't want to let go of
something that is quite good and I think
that the c-suite realizes that I think
it's underpinned by the good
infrastructure that we have in the UK we
have a tried and tested legal system we
have good dispute resolution we have a
very favorable environment for mergers
takeovers and acquisitions we understand
the liquidations and the bankruptcy laws
are good in the UK that's a really
interesting point you're saying that
brexit has actually focused people's
minds on the strengths of the city yes
yeah I really think so I also think it's
a good place to live I think people
speak English here I'm a foreigner and
it's it's a good sector and it's been
good for the UK and I think it will
continue to be so so why do people think
that New York is eventually going to
take the number one spot again risk of
taxation government maybe yeah no I
think so I think that there's a big
there's a big risk of taxing a an
industry that doesn't cost pollutants
first of all the financial services
industry doesn't cause plastic harm in
the rivers and so I think we should
protect what we have but taxation
without accountability for where all
that money will go is a clear risk
particularly for other centers are more
favorable in that regard very
interesting you say that because ghosts
the shadow chancellor john macdonald has
made
big set peach speech in the city today
in which he said there will be higher
taxes there will be a financial
transactions tax yeah I think you could
have a real risk of brain drain then and
and I I I'm not in favor of that at all
I'm in favor of protecting what we have
and realizing how much money the city
generates for the country you touch just
now on regulatory strength I mean
there's been an awful lot more
regulation of financial services since
the crisis you clearly think that we're
doing it better in the UK than in other
markets I think we understand the
regulator here I think the regulator is
transparent I think they speak in plain
English I think they have a track record
of good implementation of regulation
they take action when they have to and I
think that the industry understand what
they are playing with what about some of
these emerging financial centres and the
likes of Dubai and Mumbai well you don't
know so that's the challenge there we
don't know how those regulators act and
how they will evolve in the area of a
very complex regulation so knowing what
you're playing with is much better than
than something that is emerging that you
don't know great unknown really is the
fact that where does China want its
financial services center to be
ultimately is it gonna be in Shanghai or
is it gonna be in Hong Kong
million-dollar question
so Hong Kong is the Gateway to the
Western world Hong Kong has shown that
it has the prevailing standards of
governance and it interacts very well
with the other regulator China not so
much we don't know quite where China is
going in that regard but I do think
Shanghai will play a big role in in
global financial markets and what about
Singapore I mean Singapore's been
knocking on the door of Hong Kong for
quite a while now a lot of Brits
obviously over there now yeah someone
might kill me but it's not as
sophisticated as Hong Kong is yet they
want to be though so they're they're
doing a lot of they're taking a lot of
initiative in terms of the the regulator
the Hong Kong has a much more
tried-and-tested track record in this
regard it's much more than more of a
party city as well as now it's fun place
to be that's for sure all right morning
MELAS from Duffin folks great to see you
thank you thank you